[Music]
in 12th century england two children
were found lost in a forest they spoke
only gibberish wore strange clothing and
had bright green skin when the children
finally learned to speak english they
described where they were from and
that's why after almost a thousand years
people still talk about the green
children of wolpin in 1828 a teenage boy
was shuffling through a public square in
nuremberg he seemed confused and
disoriented he had trouble walking and
speaking when police finally approached
him he was holding an envelope
containing two letters and those letters
sparked the mystery of casper hauser in
april 1922 in brittany france
two-year-old pauline picard went missing
a massive search turned up nothing the
family was losing hope a month later
pauline was found wandering around a
village over 200 miles away though her
parents were overjoyed to have her back
they soon realized something wasn't
quite right about their daughter these
are three unsolved cases of the most
mysterious children in history
[Music]
in the 12th century woolpit was a
densely populated area in england's
suffolk county one day a local farmer
discovered two frightened children a boy
and a girl who seemed lost in the forest
as the farmer approached he noticed a
few unusual details about the children
they wore clothing of a style and color
that had never been seen before but what
was most unsettling the children had
bright green skin martians
i'm not even one minute into this thing
yet hey i can smell martian babies a
mile away can i just can i just give you
the information before you jump to a
conclusion go ahead what am i telling
you i told you so
when the farmer tried to speak to the
children they couldn't understand him
they spoke only gibberish
the children were brought to the home of
sir richard de kong a local wealthy
landowner who agreed to take them in
though the green children were clearly
starving they refused to eat oh they
didn't have any martian food in the
pantry after eating nothing for several
days sir richard's cook brought in a
bundle of beanstalks the children got
excited at the site of these and ate
green beans and nothing but green beans
raw for months and gradually sir richard
introduced a greater variety of food
into their diet and their health
improved even the green tint of their
skin went away the boy became depressed
ill and soon passed away but the girl
stayed healthy and strong
sir richard and his family continued
looking after the mysterious girl and
started to teach her english
finally able to communicate sir richard
set out to unravel the mystery of the
green children of woolpit when sir
richard asked the girl who she was and
where she was from
it didn't sound like any place on
earth you so
the young girl who took the name agnes
learned to speak english and told sir
richard her story the young boy
traveling with her was her brother they
were looking after their father's flock
when they found a cave that's when they
heard the sound of bells which agnes
described as the most beautiful and
unusual sound she'd ever heard they
followed the sound of the bells through
the cavern when they exited the other
side agnes said they felt transported to
another world that was nothing like
their own agnes said she came from an
underground village called saint
martin's land st martians saint martins
she said all the inhabitants of saint
martin's land lived underground and had
green skin above ground the land existed
in perpetual twilight though lacking
strong daylight the landscape in her
world was lush and green and there have
been a few theories as to where the
children came from the villagers thought
they were from a fairyland entrances to
fairyland were often in densely wooded
areas so many of the villagers truly
believe this theory another more modern
theory is that the children somehow
slipped into an alternate universe where
the world on their side has a much
different climate than ours this
explains the strange clothes the strange
language and the difficulty eating our
food and the most current theory is
aliens yup obviously aliens
yes that is one of the more popular
theories agnes was able to adapt to life
on earth but her brother couldn't
even though the story of the children of
woolpit is considered folklore we do
have details about them from credible
sources ralph of kog's shawl interviewed
sir richard himself and he wrote long
passages about the green children how
they were tending their flock heard the
bells and wandered into a cavern when
they emerged they were struck by the
brightness of the sun and the warmth of
the air when they heard the villagers
coming toward them they tried to flee
but they couldn't find the entrance to
the cave another source is historian
william of newburgh and though he lived
on the opposite side of the country his
telling is remarkably similar to ralph's
now ralph's writing style is colorful
and exaggerated he includes stories of
pirates and zombies so he highlights the
supernatural elements of the legend but
william of newburgh's writing is more
grounded william wrote like a journalist
just the facts no flair oh so you have
to go back a thousand years to find
journalists who actually report facts
huh it would seem so
the stories differ on what happened to
agnes later in life in one account she
stays in the service of sir richard for
many years in another version of the
story she marries an english diplomat
now unsurprisingly every time the story
is told details are changed and added
but the original works by ralph of
kogechow and william of newburgh are
considered the most reliable so no
debunking
maybe i'm gonna give you as many facts
as i can but remember these three cases
are technically still unsolved
on may 26 1828 in what is now nuremberg
germany a teenage boy was shuffling
around town he walked like a toddler and
was mumbling nonsense when police
finally approached him the picture
didn't add up the boy was dressed like
he'd been living on the street his shoes
were so worn that he had trouble walking
but he also had an expensive silk
handkerchief with the initials kh
embroidered on it and he wore an
expensive silk necktie necktie that
looks more like an ascot
what's an ascot two cheeks in a hole
at first the boy didn't say much to the
police
but he carried an envelope containing
two letters the first was addressed to a
cavalry captain the letter said the
author was not related to the boy though
he had raised him as a son the letter
also said that since the day he was born
he had never left the house so that
nobody would know where he was from the
letter went on to say that the boy could
read and write and wanted to be a
horseman like his father so the captain
could take him on or hang him whichever
he wished the letter ended rather
ominously with the author saying he had
to send the boy to nuremberg alone that
if he went with him it would have cost
him his life at the police station the
boy wrote down his name casper hauser
observers noticed that despite being 16
years old he behaved like a young child
he walked like a toddler taking his
first steps and when someone spoke to
him he would usually just speak the same
words back and despite his weird
behavior people soon realized that
casper hauser had normal intelligence
and once he calmed down he was able to
talk about where he was from and how he
arrived in the city hazard said he had
spent his entire life alone in a cell he
was fed nothing but bread and water he
was provided with a blanket and a couple
of wooden toys he had never seen his
captor even while walking to nuremberg
he was told to look down he only knew
the sound of the man's voice with
nowhere to go the local schoolmaster
george daumer agreed to take hauser in
and continue teaching him hauser
certainly acted like he was confined his
whole life the first time he saw a
mirror he looked behind it trying to
find the other boy when someone brought
him a candle he burned himself trying to
touch the flame and even though he could
eat anything he wanted the only food
that didn't repulse him was bread and
water as his communication skills
improved hauser gave more details about
his life he spoke of a recurring dream
he had where he was in an enormous
castle he saw a tall man with a sword
dressed all in black and a woman wearing
an elegant dress he wondered if this was
actually a memory over time kasper
hauser became a local celebrity a
favorite pastime for people in the city
of nuremberg was to try and figure out
the true origin of the mysterious boy
some people thought he was just a con
man addicted to the attention that he
was receiving but there was a rumor
going around that he was a lost prince
possibly the son of grand duke carvan
baden and his wife stephanie de bornet
but whether hauser's story was a lie or
the truth eventually his past would
catch up with him
one day in 1829 hauser was found in the
basement bleeding from a head wound
hauser claimed his attacker was his
captor the man that had brought him to
nuremberg the man wore a hood but he
recognized the voice that it said you
still have to die there you leave the
city of nuremberg another incident
happened a few months later when hauser
was living with a different family
hauser was shot by an attacker who he
didn't see but he later said he was
climbing on a chair to reach a book on a
high shelf he accidentally knocked a gun
off the wall when it just went off and
hauser started bouncing from home to
home and everyone who took him in said
the same thing he seems like a gentle
boy but he's a liar in 1833 casper
hauser was staying with yet another
family on december 14th he burst through
the doors of his home with a massive
wound in his chest blood was everywhere
he claimed he met a stranger in a park
who had given him a purse stabbed him
and ran off he said the purse was still
there and by now everyone was suspicious
of how hauser became injured reluctantly
police went to the scene and sure enough
there was a small purse and in the purse
there was a note written in reverse
handwriting hauser will be able to tell
you quite precisely how i look and from
where i am to save hauser the effort i
want to tell you myself from where i
come dash dash i come from dash dash
dash the bavarian border dash dash on
the river dash dash dash dash dash i
will even tell you the name
mlo
not very helpful it's not
and there were a few suspicious details
about this attack it was snowing that
day but there were only one set of
footprints found housers and the letter
was folded corner to corner which is an
unusual way to fold a letter but hauser
was known for doing this the letter also
contained grammatical errors that hauser
was known to make it was thought that
hauser attacked himself again but thrust
the knife in too far he died of his
wound three days later even after his
death people tried to unravel the
mystery of casper hauser some thought
that casper hauser was actually the
prince of baden who was born in 1812. it
was alleged that he had been switched
with a dying infant to prevent him from
inheriting the title his parents were
rumored to be carl grand duke of baden
and stephanie de bornet the adopted
daughter of napoleon and since hauser
died with no male heir whether he was a
real prince or not it no longer mattered
in 1876 historian otto middelstadt
researched the case and found no
evidence that hauser was the prince
another historian fritz trouts confirmed
middleshot's findings and said any claim
that hauser was a prince is a silly
fairy tale in 1951 letters of the grand
duke's mother were published and the
letters gave detailed accounts of the
child's birth illness and death so the
hauser as a prince theory was finally
put to rest hauser was buried in a local
cemetery where his headstone reads here
lies casper hauser riddle of his time
his birth was unknown his death
mysterious
1833. there's even a statue of him in
the old city center at the very place
where hauser first appeared his life was
a mystery for a hundred years and now
the statue of casper hauser can fuel the
imagination of others for hundreds of
years to come
the picards lived on a farm in brittany
france two-year-old pauline was one of
nine children one day in april 1922
pauline was playing outside with her
brothers and sisters something the kids
did every day when they were summoned
for dinner pauline wasn't among them
within a few hours 150 people combed
every inch of the farm and the
surrounding area there was no sign of
her as time went on rumors began to
circulate maybe a wild boar had attacked
an eaten her there was a suspicious
chimney cleaner in town who a few weeks
earlier tried to give pauline candy
neighbors said they saw two strangers
hanging around the farm about the same
time pauline disappeared but even in the
best possible scenario that none of the
rumors were true there was no way a
two-year-old could survive in the
elements for this long
while soon the pain and loss set in the
picards would never see their daughter
again then about a month later the
family would get a miracle a young girl
was found wandering around the town of
cherbourg about 200 miles from brittany
the girl was scared alone and on foot
the police showed a photo to the picards
they couldn't believe it it was pauline
colleen's parents went to retrieve her
but when they finally saw her pauline
didn't seem to react the picard sat with
her they talked to her but she seemed
distant the picards were worried pauline
was in shock but doctors said that aside
from being malnourished she was
perfectly healthy then they started to
wonder if this actually was their
daughter she looked like her same hair
same blue eyes same features but there
was this kernel of doubt in her parents
minds
still they took her home hoping that
familiar surroundings would spark her
memory pauline's sisters immediately
recognized her which was a huge relief
for her parents pauline's family figured
it would just take time before life
would get back to normal would life get
back to normal
not even close
[Music]
a few weeks later a farmer crossing a
field about a mile from the picard's
farm found the body of a young girl near
the body neatly folded were pauline's
clothes the same clothes she was wearing
the day she went missing and also nearby
was a skull of a grown man
now it seems there were two murders to
solve the field where pauline was found
had been searched when she went missing
so police believe the body was placed
there more recently the neatly folded
clothes implied a murder but the autopsy
was inconclusive doctors thought dying
of cold was just as likely as murder
there were two suspects that police
seriously considered the first was one
of the picard's farmhands named caramon
the day pauline disappeared he had been
invited for breakfast he was said to
have cuddled her a little too much and
someone heard him telling pauline on
more than one occasion that he would
find her a good home in a different town
and at one pm that day he was alone with
pauline and someone overheard him
telling her that she was going with him
police followed the path he would have
taken but ultimately decided the timing
just didn't match up then a local farmer
named yves martin stopped by the picards
he said he'd heard pauline had been
found they told him she had he then
blurted out god forgive me i am guilty
and ran from the farm screaming and
laughing the next day he was taken to a
lunatic asylum although he confessed to
the murder no other evidence has ever
been found no other clues or suspects
emerged and pauline's death remains a
mystery
[Music]
so what can we unravel from these three
stories first the green children of
woolpit uh you mean the green martian
children at planet mars uh unlikely
given what was going on in that area of
england during the 12th century i think
we could put together what really
happened in 1173 king henry faced the
great revolt an uprising by his eldest
sons supported by france scotland and
flanders
flanders is the northern part of belgium
where flemish is spoken and there were a
lot of flemish immigrants in england
during the great revolt the battle of
fornum was fought just a few miles from
woolpit eventually an uneasy peace was
reached but king henry angry at the
flemish mercenaries was persecuting
flemish settlers all this was going on
at the exact time the green children
were found it's most likely that the
children were refugees from a battle or
simply fleeing english soldiers who are
harassing the settlement the flemish
language which is a dialect of dutch
would have sounded like gibberish to
english farmers and the flemish were
known for wearing clothes that were very
different than english as for the green
skin there's a condition called
chlorosis or hypochromic anemia which is
a type of iron deficiency it even had a
nickname back then the green sickness if
the children were refugees fleeing a
battle they were most likely living off
of whatever they can scrounge from the
land lack of meat would explain the lack
of iron and also why they would eat
nothing but raw green beans for months
but as the children ate a more diverse
diet their green skin returned to normal
why the boy died is not entirely clear
some speculate it could have been
arsenic poisoning though arsenic
typically acts faster nobody really
knows the caves the children spoke of do
exist in the area flint and chalk mines
are everywhere and the cave would be a
good place to hide from a battle or from
soldiers in fact there are large caves
between woolpit and the small village of
fornum the site of several battles
during the great revolt and the church
of fornham was called saint martin's
church when the girl said she was from
saint martin's land this is likely what
she meant all of these details mixed
with the fuzzy memories of a terrified
child it's easy to see how this legend
was born still these are just best
guesses nobody really knows who the
children were or where they were from
now casper hauser the real mystery is
who was he remember several historians
debunked the idea that he was a prince
they used public records and private
letters to prove this
the problem with public records and
private letters people lie right
people lie
but dna doesn't after a couple of
hit-and-miss tests in the 90s a dna test
in 2002 yielded an astonishing result
hair and skin samples from hauser's
clothes were tested they proved with 95
percent accuracy but he was related to
princess josephine of badden whose
mother was stephanie dibo dibuharnae von
baden he actually was a prince well
there's a 95 chance he was the only way
to know with 100 certainty is to test
the dna of his alleged mother and the
dna of the child buried as her son but
the house of baden has declined to
participate of course
our final mystery is the case of paulie
picard unfortunately there is not much
else to report it was assumed that the
killer was yves martin the farmer
committed to an asylum but no physical
evidence was ever found that could link
him to the murder so who was the girl
living with them this whole time nobody
knows she barely spoke after learning
the true fate of pauline the picards
didn't know what to do with the girl
they sent her to an orphanage where she
died a few months later of measles her
name has been lost to history
but the stories of the green children of
woolpit casper hauser and pauline picard
have not been lost to history they're
now part of it and who knows with enough
time we may finally get the answers to
these mysteries but until then they
remain
unsolved
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps and if you have any
tips or topics to suggest you can go to
the whyfiles.com tips i can't cover
every story but i read every suggestion
special thanks to our generous patrons
who made this channel possible we
couldn't do it without you and if you'd
like to support the y-files by becoming
a patron or by buying some y-files
merchandise there are links in the
description until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you